un ritual a la pachamama para que
devuelva a los cuerpos de los
desaparecidos en la masacre de la
cantuta
un caso de los años 90 en el perú de
fujimori nueve estudiantes y un profesor
fueron secuestrados acusados de ser
guerrilleros y posteriormente masacrados
e incinerados y enterrados en este punto
apartado el dolor no se ha borrado del
corazón de sus familiares a ojalá que
dios quiera que nos encontramos aún que
sea un pedazo de mí por ser realmente
que no lo estoy con no estoy bien cuando
no le encuentro a mí
las excavaciones fueron iniciadas por la
fiscalía peruana allí un grupo de
expertos intenta ubicar los cuerpos en
un área de 150 metros de largo y 50 de
ancho lo que se trata de hacer ahora es
descartar la posibilidad de que en este
lugar habrían más restos óseos humanos
carbonizados relacionados a este caso la
posibilidad de que los cuerpos no
aparezcan existe pero los familiares no
pierden la esperanza de encontrar sus
restos y poder llorar los en paz pensar
de que al final de cuentas nunca vas a
encontrar alguna evidencia alguna
alguna algún cuerpo para cerrar ese
duelo es bien difícil pensar que esa
seriedad se pueden cerrar sin embargo sí
creo yo que hay que hacer los esfuerzos
de alcanzar justicia
esta masacre sumó años de prisión para
alberto fujimori
en perú el caso de la cantuta es
considerado como uno de los peores
crímenes contra los derechos humanos en
dos décadas de conflicto interno